from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Pop-Tarts in the US and the UK
this is food Wars
in the UK Pop-Tarts come in one main
size an eight pack you might also be
able to find a 36 pack online but these
seem more geared towards retailers
rather than consumers so for the
purposes of food Wars we're not counting
them in the US our Pop-Tarts come in
seven size varieties down here with the
two pack eight pack toe wealth pack 16
pack the value pack 32 pack the family
pack and if you can see it's family in
there and the biggest amount to 48 pack
they probably also come in one box that
means our biggest Pop-Tart variety is
33.3 percent bigger than what you can
get in the UK but other Pop Tarts the
same size in both countries let's
measure them to find out so our UK
popped up was eight centimeters wide and
11 centimeters long for a surface area
of 88 centimeters squared we will do the
same
three Buy
four
and of course we're gonna weigh it and a
pop tart in the US weighs 48 grams our
UK pops out was Bank on 50 grams which I
think is actually slightly more than
it's supposed to wear Kellogg's uh woke
up feeling a little generous today but
what about the pastry to filling ratio I
hear you cry well don't worry we're
gonna look at that too you can sort of
like chisel off layers of pastry
I mean there's pretty not much Jam in
there that's a very thin layer of jam
right there I think we might have to
Imagine This it's gone real bad so
unfortunately we had to abandon the
scrape test because that was not working
Joe if you pulled that off you're a
genius I don't know how you've done it
however on the back of the box of the
Pop-Tarts it says that the fruit filling
should be 34 of the pop tart by weight
if our matter correct this was a 50 gram
popped up 34 of that should be 17 grams
of jam
yeah anyway all right hot hot hot
mmm
let me get wiping it on here right
we'll round up to 10 grams
so that is
this percentage of
Jam
here's all the Pop-Tarts you can get in
the US you can't get in the UK and here
are all the pop tarts from the UK that
you can't find in the US yes it's just
the one
we got all of them want to get this out
of the way real quick there are
currently two limited edition Pop-Tarts
out right now the red white and
blueberry and the Frosted strawberry
throwback I went to Walmart guy said
they didn't have them also newer ones
there is an Apple Jacks frosted apple
cinnamon one which is supposed to be
delivered to my house tomorrow I'm sorry
but one new one we do have is frosted
banana bread which is looks like a
Pop-Tart gave us an extra frosting up
top there
yeah it tastes like banana bread that's
just very good you can only find three
Pop-Tart varieties on sale in the UK
including strawberry sensation frosted
choco-tastic and hot fudge sundae these
two you can also find in the US so
they're not exclusives but this one is
the Frosted chocolate while it has its
own name it does seem a little bit
similar to the U.S chocolate fudge one
so we'll take it out and have a look so
this is a UK frosted choco-tastic Pop
Tart it's got the chocolate icing the
pastry itself is chocolate flavored and
it's got these little flecks of white
stuff on it ambitiously in my mind I was
hoping might be like flaky sea salt but
it's a Pop Tart I think it's more like
this should be some icing
not too bad you also have a chocolatey
filling on that as well
so it's kind of like three levels of
chocolate going on here not too sweet
either actually all right starting with
the Frosted chocolate fudge now let's
compare this to what Harry got
chocolate and chocolate
I was gonna say the obvious but there's
like really chocolatey and fudgy as soon
as we only have three Pop Tarts I
figured I'd try the other ones too just
to see how they Stack Up Against The
Exclusive chocolatastic so this is our
version of hot fudge sundae pastry wise
looks kind of similar to the chocolate
one with the chocolate pastry but then
it has something more resembling the
strawberry icing I feel like this is
probably a slightly lazy attempt to just
kind of rehash things I already have
into a new product The Filling looks
pretty similar to The Filling found on
the Frosted chocolatastic slightly
lighter in color so maybe I've gone for
more of a fudge Vibe rather than just
straight chocolate
I think with a combination of the
standard icing and the slightly
different filling this has more of a
well-rounded balanced sweet flavor to it
and of course the classic strawberry
Pop-Tart obviously visually this stands
out because they have not gone for the
chocolate pastry it's that very kind of
almost alarmingly pale pastry color
pretty much the same icing I think that
they've used on the chunk fudge sundae
for a reason
it's just really good it's a blueberry
all right getting some fruit I wouldn't
be able to guess what fruit this
vegetable on the outside I'm in
for one thing I've noticed there is
skimping on the filling I know it's like
dusty but brown sugar cinnamon beat up
ooh this is like really smooth also very
dusty
I honestly can't help the flavor is the
frosting or the jam Cherry I mean I feel
this is like a flagship one aim's not so
great over there in the factory already
though both on this side and this side
you can almost see the filling coming
out of it right
I'm starting to think a lot of the sweet
fruit flavor is coming from the frosting
and not the inside
chocolate chip I already this can we get
that sad trombone please it's like so
it's like a doctor's signature it's just
right across it I can't read this what
does this say oh Pop-Tart
oh this really irritates me this really
winds me up oh you got to be kidding me
with this
your mom or your school or your work
whatever doesn't get Oreos they get the
knockoff brand
sandwich cookies and it's like you'll
eat them but you're like ah man kind of
wanted Oreos that's what this tastes
like it says like a knockoff of an Oreo
frosted confetti uh
don't make me eat this please don't make
me eat this
it's like just eating straight frosting
next up frosted hot fudge sundae
breakfast is served this looks like an
absolute nightmare imagine eating this
and going to school totally phoned in
like that drizzle
it's very sweet
oh man a Pop-Tart s'mores you release
choice
okay let me tastes like a s'mores you
can see a little pocket of marshmallow
there this is the first dual filling I
think I've had at least I've noticed and
you know what I don't really like it
I can't believe we only had one
exclusive I feel like I'm really missing
out on some of those tasty American Pop
Tarts Joey can I get some of those no
worries man I gotcha
thank you so it looks like Joe has
kindly shared with me some confetti
cupcake Pop-Tarts the American version
of the hot fudge sundae Pop-Tarts and
some frosted s'mores Pop-Tarts frosted
confetti I feel like Americans are just
obsessed with eating sprinkles because
it seems like every kind of brand
whether it's chocolate pastry will have
a kind of confetti cupcake birthday cake
flavor and Pop-Tarts and no exception
American sprinkles look so much better
than British sprinkles I know it's
because they are using banned chemicals
which we don't have over here we have to
opt for natural alternatives but when it
comes to baking they just hold their
color so much better they look a lot
more vibrant I kind of get why you guys
are using her
doesn't give me any pleasure to admit it
but that is really tasty
it's got almost like a sort of cake
batter taste to it that filling so it
kind of is like you're eating a confetti
cupcake or at least the batter of a
confetti cupcake in my left hand I have
a British strawberry sensation popped up
in my right hand I have the American
frosted confetti cupcake one just
quickly wanted to point out the color
difference because that is wild next up
is the American version of the hot podge
sundae Pop-Tarts the American version of
these looks so much more fun than ours
size wise they look pretty much the same
but the American one looks thicker
the American one has this white icing
filling whereas in the UK I think
they've gone for more of a kind of like
fudgy chocolate filling the difference
between these two is Kind of Night and
Day the American one better than ours
and pretty much everywhere I tasted this
at first and I wasn't disappointed by it
per se but now that I've had the
comparison a direct comparison with the
US this sounds like eating cardboard
finally it's the Frosted s'mores Pop
Tart I gotta say s'mores aren't really a
thing in the UK in the UK we don't have
graham crackers or as we would pronounce
it graham crackers shout out to my dad
Graham
yeah there we go
there we go it's almost like a digestive
biscuit these are pretty good this one
looks maybe the scariest it's cookies
and cream
whenever it's frosting inside I know I'm
in trouble
yuck don't give this to a child ever and
most adults should also not eat this
grape grape
fruit ones look how I think a pops are
supposed to look they don't look that
intimidating
grape is a really popular flavor in the
U.S but anyone in the US will tell you
that grape flavored candy doesn't really
taste like grapes they somehow
invented a grape-like flavor probably
because grapes have like a weaker flavor
I think I'm not quite sure exactly how
it came to be but this tastes exactly
like that fake imitation Bubblicious
bubble gum grape you know I'm talking
about a grape soda it's not bad so far
all the fruit ones are better than any
of the other ones so yeah Eggo
how unnatural looking is this you know
you can take those classes I think it's
called like Sip and paint where everyone
Paints the same picture same still life
while they're sipping wine with their
friends this was the image they were
painting and this is what they painted
drunk
this does not in any way tastes like an
Eggo waffle I don't think there's like
waffles at all what ruins it is this
frosting on here this is so sweet
raspberry I have a feeling this is gonna
be a good one yeah
top chair right here these were
optimized for fruit filling wild berry
so it's just the combinations wild or
these were found in the wild oh no alarm
bells in my caveman DNA is going off do
not eat this is poisonous do not eat
warning warning ancestors who ate this
died let's go against millions of years
of evolution and bite into this woefully
bright colored piece of I'm assuming
food we'll find out together
it's actually not that sweet compared to
the other fruit ones
play this part of the video to uh the
ambulance driver
when he asks what happened Boston cream
Boston cream donut is this donut right
here if you haven't seen it and you
can't even tell where the cream is in
the compared to the color of the pastry
what I'm about to say will come as no
surprise to anyone watching this video
but this one tastes completely
artificial I know right can you believe
it on to the next smaller pyramid
snickerdoodle
Bland all right look at the unfrosted
ones unfrosted unfrost we got strawberry
brown sugar cinnamon and blueberry
unfrosted v-frosted I was complaining
how sweet they were so maybe I'm more of
an unfrosted guy and I don't realize
that but this looks weird
this looks like an army ration
this one is sweeter but not that much
sweeter don't you think with the
frosting would be night and day they're
pretty similar simply frosted Harvest
strawberry there you go no artificial
colors color from natural sources
once again regular strawberry Top Pop
Tarts they look pretty similar right
this one even has more frosting on it
wow they taste exactly the same as the
artificial ones
one other thing that we wanted to talk
about was The Toasted versus untoasted
Pop-Tarts debate now people have been
debating for years whether it's better
to eat your Pop-Tarts toasted or
straight out of the packet I will say in
the UK this is less of a debate because
I feel like most people are more likely
to toast their Pop Tarts even though
they are safe to eat straight out of the
packet however we did notice that on the
American ones that Joe sent over there
are some varying instructions which kind
of confused us apparently in the US you
can microwave them which you're supposed
to do in bursts of three seconds until
they're hot enough to eat despite the
fact that the British ones explicitly
tell you to not microwave them I'm
assuming at some point someone tried to
microwave them in the foil and was met
with a nasty surprise and also the
American ones say that you can freeze
them and eat them Frozen don't know why
you would do that Frozen or semi-frozen
pastry does not sound like it would be
nice but we're not ever microwaved or
frozen Pop-Tarts we're just going to
heat a couple up in the toaster oven and
then compare them to some untoasted pop
tarts to see which ones I prefer all
right toasty boy going in let's see if
we can Rectify that
also
what did you notice what is with Harry's
giant toaster oven and then the size of
that thing is get a regular toaster
well it's like toasted pastry
oh
and it's falling apart so it's breaking
apart already
and toasted
yeah toast is way better the filling is
more flavorful the crispiness of the
pastry added some too lazy to toast them
so this one on my right is the untasted
version and on my left is the toasted
version I gotta say visually not a lot
has changed I was hoping for a little
bit more Browning while I was in the
oven still not much of a snap from the
pastry even when toasted but you can see
that the filling has slightly liquefied
it's really impressive that they've
actually managed to create a pastry that
doesn't just burst and leak all of the
filling when it does get toasted I say
impressive probably just uses a lot of
chemicals whereas when you compare it to
the untoasted one even when you kind of
Squish it down that filling is not going
anywhere
I do prefer the toasted version as I
sort of expected I think the main
difference for me is actually in the
filling obviously the flavor doesn't
change a lot when you toast it it's more
than texture I think just the fact that
it doesn't liquefy slightly gives it a
much more pleasant texture when you
actually bite into this thing also in
the US you get something called Pop
Tarts bites these guys right here I have
strawberry of course and confetti cake
but you can also get brown sugar
cinnamon frosted blueberry price of
chocolate fudge and strawberry banana I
have no idea what these are
no this is not good Pop-Tarts also does
collabs with other brands for instance
there's a Pop-Tarts Jenny's ice cream
coffee mate has its own Pop-Tarts flavor
and of course Pop Tart cereal it was
originally called Pop-Tarts crunch
discontinued but they renamed it after
they brought it back
UK an eight pack of strawberry Pop-Tarts
cost you two pounds 99 Pence which is
around 3.86 that same box in the US is
4.49 or 3 pounds 47 a 16.3 percent
increase in the US
with the gouging come on guys it's not
surprising me that Pop-Tarts are really
popular in the us we love a quick and
convenient breakfast they have
positioned themselves in their
advertising as a more convenient
breakfast than cereal because you know
inconvenient cereal is you got to get
the box and the bowl and the spoon and
the milk and sit down and eat it and
that Pop-Tarts cereal too much work
Pop-Tarts way easier for me the price
increase proportion makes sense because
I've always seen Pop Tarts as more of a
treat than an everyday breakfast food it
was the sort of thing that my mom might
have let me had as like a weekend treat
breakfast if I had accompanied on her
weekly shop and been very well behaved I
will say that the marketing in the UK
explicitly doesn't brand these as a
breakfast food compared to something
like cereal there is no mention of the
word breakfast anywhere on here the that
just referred to as toaster pastries so
I guess they could be construed as more
of a snack is the lack of breakfast
talking the same in the U.S Joe or are
you guys a bit less Shameless about
marketing desserts as breakfast foods
for children so I originally thought
this was supposed to be breakfast food
but Harry makes a good point it doesn't
say breakfast anywhere on here even the
box says you can go straight from the
foil toasted stacked or frozen but they
really are not saying anything about
breakfast so I went back and looked
online in the 90s I looked on YouTube I
found a bunch of commercials where they
said specifically for breakfast they
even quote part of your complete
breakfast so they did sometimes Market
them as breakfast foods and sometimes
not and just for me it sunken then yeah
you have these for breakfast in the
morning when you're in a hurry to get to
school or work
here is the nutritional information for
one strawberry Pop-Tart in the UK
let's be honest they come in packs of
two so we're going to double those
numbers for a more accurate serving size
reading thank you Eric because in the US
we go straight for the two tart serving
size and here our strawberry Pop-Tarts
are
it looks like the UK numbers are
actually slightly higher than those in
the US so I guess that means we're
winning now if calories are your thing
in the U.S our cinnamon brown sugar
Pop-Tarts have the most 400 per serving
how about weights
the unfrosted
have even more calories
410 per serving
I don't know how that works either in
2021 somebody sued Kellogg's claiming
that Pop-Tarts contained way less
strawberry than what was presented on
the packaging this case is ultimately
dismissed as the judge said quote no
reasonable consumer could believe from
Kellogg's packaging at The Breakfast
Table hey breakfast perfect okay
contains only strawberries or more
strawberries than other ingredients such
as pears and apples the U.S packaging
actually states that the strawberry
Pop-Tarts contain two percent or less of
dry strawberries
here are all the ingredients of a UK
strawberry sensation frosted Pop-Tart
one thing to note is that the gelatin
used in a UK Pop-Tart is explicitly
labeled as beef gelatin so unfortunately
this means that British Pop Tarts are
not suitable for vegetarians and here
are all the ingredients in a U.S
strawberry popcorn
of the many differences between these
two lists there are a few ingredients we
wanted to highlight here the first is
tbhq or tert beautiful hydroquinone
yeah
to be honest quite
this is a preservative which is used to
extend shelf life or for added freshness
as the US label States the FDA has plug
limits on how much it can be used tbhq
can account for more than .02 percent of
the oils in a food because the FDA
doesn't have evidence that greater
amounts are safe while that doesn't mean
that more than 0.02 percent is dangerous
it does indicate that higher safety
levels haven't been determined research
has linked tbhq to health problems the
National Library of Medicine found
Vision disturbances when it was consumed
by humans as well as liver enlargement
neurotoxic effects convulsions and
paralysis in laboratory animals Pop
Tarts in the US also contain synthetic
food coloring which are restricted in
the UK specifically Yellow 5 yellow 6
red 40. because of the link to
hyperactivity and inattention in
children Gali G I can't imagine why the
brain is going all over the place
another thing to note is that the
Pop-Tarts choice at me are technically
Contraband items if you're working with
the police or the government and you
watch this please do not extradite Joe
we need him for filming that's because
the flower used in U.S Pop Tarts is
bleached bleaching flour has been banned
in the UK since the 1990s over concerns
about potential health effects it also
just seems unnecessary to me especially
for something that's going to be toasted
and darkening color anyway you guys
would love putting chemicals in your
food and seem to see any opportunity you
can to do it yeah don't arrest me but he
did ask me to send it so I will flip and
the UK team in a second FBR if you're
watching I will wear a wire it was all
Harry's idea I will help you take him
down
current season of Love Island UK so I'm
like are you joking are you joking
you're having a laugh me having a laugh
this is journalism baby this is why we
went to journalism school I didn't go to
journalism school so I have an excuse